[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau date année
d'interdire les antilles françaises
connaissent depuis deux semaines une
grave crise sociale née du refus de
l'obligation vaccinale pour les pompiers
et le personnel de santé qui a dégénéré
en revendications contre la vie chère
provoquant des violences des incendies
des barrages routiers et des blessés un
gendarme a reçu jeudi une balle dans la
jambe le couvre feu a été prolongée
depuis la tension est un peu retombée
notamment guadeloupe loup l'un des plus
gros barrage a été démantelé par les
forces de l'ordre mais les problèmes
restent entiers et d'être parfois d'il
ya longtemps pour en débattre nous avons
invité luc laventure vous êtes
journaliste martiniquais vous avez
travaillé à france 3 martinique à rfo
vous avez été directeur des antennes de
france ô vous êtes aujourd'hui président
et directeur de la rédaction l'outre-mer
360 un site d'information qui couvre
l'ensemble des actualités ultramarines
c'est quoi pour vous le problème des
antilles
singularité
singularité du point de vue de
l'identité singularité de la façon du
rapport au monde sait que je l'arrêté
par rapport à la loi singularité en
étant français totalement français avec
le droit non seulement du sol mais du
sang et puis le fait qu' on revendique
quand même une certaine autonomie
sur le plan de la relation au monde déjà
un hub rêvez vous êtes guadeloupéen de
naissance fondatrice de l'agencé caisse
communication vice-présidente du conseil
représentatif des français d'outre-mer
c'est quoi pour vous le problème des
antilles un certain nombre de problèmes
d'inégalité non résolus des inégalités
mis sur la table depuis toujours et
toujours avec ces mêmes problèmes qui
reviennent chômage vif
r1 pollution
anne marie le pourhiet vous êtes juriste
spécialisé en droit constitutionnel
professeur à l'université rennes 1 vous
avez vécu et enseigné pendant six ans
guadeloupe l université des antilles à
pointe à pitre votre dernier livre
juridiquement correct histoire de la
mise sous tutelle de la démocratie
française est paru chez l'artilleur en
septembre et il ya quelques jours vous
avez publié dans le figaro vox une
tribune sur la situation aux antilles
alors vous pouvez la résumer c'est quoi
le problème pour vous en dit si c'est un
système économique et social qui est
aberrant mais qui est irréformable donc
je ne ce sera des soubresauts comme ça
tout le temps mais c'est que c'est comme
ça depuis toujours
tout ce qu'il faudrait faire ne peut pas
être fait non donc à chaque fois c'est
l'impuissance vous nous expliquerez sans
détails dans un instant claudy siar
fondateur de tropic fm journaliste à rfi
vous avez été délégué interministériel
pour l'égalité des chances des français
d'outre-mer aujourd'hui vice président
du conseil représentatif des français
d'outre-mer le problème pour vous
beaucoup de choses viennent d'être dit
on pourrait ajouter ça me semble
important il ya le poids de l'histoire
il y à des territoires qui
structurellement parlant
pose problème dans leur rapport à la
france et j'aime a répété que l'état
français traitent l'outre-mer comme les
confettis de son ancien empire colonial
alors première question d'abord lié à la
vaccination puisque ça a été le
détonateur l'obligation vaccinale a été
le détonateur de la révolte et
l'obligation vaccinale des pompiers et
des soignants vous l'expliquez comment
je l'expliqué par le fait que les
pompiers trouve incroyable cette
rapidité de vouloir être vaccinés de
vouloir les pousser à être vaccinés
d'avoir un pass sanitaires alors qu'il
ya quelques temps il y avait le problème
du chlordécone où il y avait un demandes
de
dédommagement et de prise en compte de
ce pesticide qui a
qui a pollué les terres les cordes
1972 à 93 répondu dans les champs de
bananes dans les champs de bananes donc
il ya des familles dont les parents sont
morts de cancer il ya une une
un cancer qui se propage dans plusieurs
familles et donc il trouve aberrant que
on puisse
on puisse rapidement leur demander de se
vacciner et qu'on ne puisse pas prendre
aussi rapidement en compte ce problème
des pesticides qui a contaminé les
terres les hommes double aventure je ne
suis pas sociologue je ne pourrais pas
décrypter les choses totalement je le
disais tout à l'heure je pense qu'un
rapport à la loi
il ya un rapport à l'environnement qui
fait que au niveau de la santé le
rapport au corps n'est pas le même nous
avons une esthétique si je puis dire du
point de vue médical avec ce qu'on
appelle les médias dit le fait qu' on
est très proche
des médicaments naturels ce qu'on
appelle les médicaments naturels et puis
un rapport à la loi qui est
qu'ils aillent bien de le dire un
scepticisme et que ces infos scepticisme
ou bien est ce que c'est quelque chose
qui qui qui relève de notre côté rétifs
je ne sais pas mais il y a quelque chose
de cela donc a priori quand on vous
impose un médicament et avec sa valeur
je ne suis pas sûr que la notion de un
fusil le médicament sera le terme exact
pardon je pense que
imposer une loi impose et imposer une
façon de faire
on est un petit peu rétif vis-à-vis de
cela marie le pourhiet vous savez la
bretagne est infesté par les nitrates
qui empoisonnent allègrement également
la bretagne et c'est pas de ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui les algues vertes on
connaît on a les mêmes choses or à ma
connaissance les départements des côtes
d'armor et du finistère sont les plus
vaccinée de france donc il ya aucun lien
pensable entre le chlordécone et le
refus du vaccin le chlordécone c'est un
poison le vaccin c'est pour sauver des
vies et pour éviter la contamination
d'une île qui est particulièrement
sujette à la contamination donc c'est
aberrant salle sant est irrationnel il
n'y a aucun lien pensable et imaginables
entre les deux donc je pense que là il
ya un gros il ya un gros prétexte quand
même donc le 10 hier la mort fut
non moi je pense pas que la grande
bretagne n'a pas la même histoire vous
savez les territoires d'outre-mer ont
une histoire de france donc toute
l'histoire qu'on connaît une spécificité
historique ensuite il ya aussi ce la
grande bretagne je pense que quand il ya
des problèmes en grande bretagne la
france
les eaux sont la france les résout
beaucoup plus vite d'accord donc
l'histoire n'est pas pareil donc étant
donné qu'au lieu de l'histoire n'est pas
pareil vous savez quand il ya eu
l'esclavagé a été aboli et ça a été
rétablie ça a été rétablie par l'état ça
a été rétablie par une loi ça a été
rétablie par des hommes bien pensants
voyez donc en fait il ya une une
multitude de choses historiques qui font
que le rapport à la loi et le n'est pas
le même que qu'on les bretons et les
guadeloupéens et les martiniquais claudy
siar alors effectivement en réalité il y
a
ce rapport compliqué de ces france et
français
certains diront totalement français
depuis la loi de départementalisation du
19 mars 46 mais depuis cette date là qui
a été ce qui était censé mettre un terme
à une pauvreté endémique guadeloupe
martinique guyane réunion mais depuis
cette date là des femmes et des hommes
se battent pour une égalité réelle
aujourd'hui la guadeloupe et la
martinique sont coupé en deux il ya
celles et ceux qui comprennent
l'importance de la vaccination
l'importance de je me protège te protège
et une solidarité pas seulement
française mais une solidarité mondiale
et puis il y a les autres effectivement
qui sont dans ce scepticisme la en
rappelant quand même qu'une majorité une
grande majorité des du personnel
soignant et vacciner chez nous en
guadeloupe et en martinique de rappeler
ça mais en réalité ce qui explique cette
scission une fois qu'on a dit ça il faut
quand même juste dire que la majorité
des entiers sont d'accord pour dénoncer
les inégalités de traitement la
relégation persistante et là on a
affaire à l'état puis je vais vous dire
comment vous pouvez expliquer à des gens
dans l'histoire est particulière qu'elle
a dit
vous l'avez rappelé également tous les
deux comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer
que ces français là est un ministère qui
au quotidien régis leurs vies c'est à
dire vous avez un ministère qui est
jusqu'en 1959 était le ministère des
colonies est donc comment pouvez vous
avoir votre 10 ministre de la
coopération aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de
ministère de la coopération
et qui était et qui était et qui était
d'ailleurs c'est dans le même hôtel
particulier parisien
comment pouvez vous dire à des franges
vous êtes totalement français lorsque ce
sont les territoires colonisés et on met
de côté la corse
comment pouvez vous être totalement
français donc lorsque des et puis et
puis à des épisodes aussi dans
l'histoire on pourrait effectivement le
plus récent et en 2009 on pourrait aller
beaucoup plus loin sur la guadeloupe la
martinique 74 en martinique lorsque la
police tire sont des ouvriers qui ne
réclame que lors du on pourrait remonter
à 56 également 67 en guadeloupe les
années 50 également edouard glissant
était l'un de ceux qui étaient justement
dans la clandestinité parce qu'il était
recherché par la police tous ces
épisodes la font partie du récit des
imaginaires des entier et donc qui via
cette méfiance systématique souvent mais
est ce et cette confusion là étonne
certains d'entre nous et on peut
l'expliquer alors je les retiens pardon
je je je vais relativiser tout ça parce
qu'on apprenait de la bretagne vous avez
raison
la bretonne avec la révolution c'est que
j'ai quand même quelque chose de ce
sirop de lavande et c'est quelque chose
d'assez rude
la révolution arrive et on dit on
affiche à strasbourg on arrive on
affiche en alsace vous n'avez plus le
droit de parler alsacien c'est quand
même un choc terrible de la révolution
c'est à dire que ces soubresauts ne
concerne pas dans l'histoire et tu a
raison de le dire ne concerne pas
seulement les antilles cautionne tout
regarder la façon dont le pacte
vaccinale a été opérée su du côté de
marseille comment elle était perçue en
bretagne et comment elle était perçue
dans la région parisienne chaque chaque
chaque chaque région a sa spécificité
lavaur mac vous m'accorderez qu'il ya
quand même une spécificité particulière
puisque le faible taux de vaccination
aux antilles à la réunion aussi en
guyane oui
comment explique-t-on parce que ça n'est
pas que les en mairie et la guadeloupe
mais je dise exactement comme dans le
sud de l'hexagone il ya le rapport au
temps et un rapport à l'espace le
rapport au corps qui n'est pas le même
rapport à l'environnement qui n'est pas
le même et tant qu'on ne combat pas ici
de décrypter cela on va se focaliser sur
des points
précis de l'histoire qui sont des
prétextes mais je pense que chaque
région a son identité et son identité
elle est multiple et je pense que ce ne
serait pas en dix minutes qu'on va
arriver à décortiquer quelque chose sur
lesquels l'aide sociale c'est que si si
si vous dites à des personnes à vous
avez un rapport avec la loi qui n'est
pas possible bombe a coûté on va vous
dispensez que vous arrêter aux hommes je
n'ai pas le rouge je n'ai pas dit cela
mais ça se retourne contre qui qui qui
est victime de ce système de la
dérogation de l'exonération mais qui qui
va souffrir de l'absence de vaccin
vous imaginez bien que si l'état cède et
dix bombes a très bien pas de
vaccination plus obligatoire ni pas
sanitaire au gentil je pense à ça va
être immédiatement dénoncé un
mail ou la persécution sanitaire des
personnes et on lui reprochera la même
chose qu'on me reproche pour le corps
des codes sont dits d'accord moment
décisif vers son avis le contraire à la
vérité
c'est à dire que moi ce que j'ai vécu je
suis prof de droit public je précise
c'est important c'est à dire la primauté
de l'intérêt général sur les intérêts
individuels c'est pas moi d'abord c'est
le collectif d'abord et ça c'est quelque
chose qui a du mal à pénétrer dans des
sociétés qui sont restés de type féodal
comme la corse là aussi l'incivisme
civilisé l'incivisme et quelque chose de
très fréquents dans ces petits société
où on a l'habitude de demander au maire
à l'élu haut responsable c'est ça pour
moi un fait desroches desroches donne
moi un avantage dont notamment un fillon
demande manque quelque chose et donc on
écarte la règle de droit public égal
pour tous pour donner un privilège alain
ceci à l'eau et avec un fonctionnement
comme ça moi ça m'a toujours frappé que
ont trouvé des excuses au fait que le
code de la route soit complètement
ignorer délibérément pas par des jeunes
antillais mais il se retrouvait aux
urgences à la meynard bon complètement
cassé en mille morceaux par leurs excès
de vitesse vous n'allez pas dire
on va hausser les épaules devant la
violation du systématique du de la route
et en cause comment considérez vous la
dérogation qui a été donnée pour un
pesticide qui étaient interdits partout
et qui a été autorisé aux antilles donc
cette dérogation vous l'acceptez vous la
comprenez celle là je ne l'acceptent pas
du tout mais je sais je ne sais pas mais
vous venez de médias n'accordent pas les
années à venir de dérogation leurs
revendications complètement farfelu wiki
pas donc qui avait demandé la dérogation
avez vous deviné vraiment avait dit le
penser qu'elle allait venir parler comme
cela dans l'esprit d'un haut
fonctionnaire enfin voyons qu'elle a été
exigée par le milieu local vous croyez
le lieu local que les retards en
bretagne ou dans les allées la
l'augmentation des nitrates ça vient de
paris mais combien pour les agriculteurs
c'est ce sont tous les lobbys loccoz
sont les élus locaux qui au nom du
chantal lauby locales lundi il n'existe
faut sauver la patrie locale a cité les
puisque vous venez du droit et vous
venez de dire donc ce sont des sujets
que vous maîtrisez willoughby locale
quels élus locaux non mais quel lobby
locale parce que vous parlez de
dérogation farfelue il n'y a jamais de
demandes farfelues les demandes doivent
être analysés en fonction de
l'environnement il n'y a jamais de
dérogation farfelue mais les dérogations
du chlordécone qui empoisonnent des
terres et jusqu'à présent ces familles
qui demandent qui revendiquent des
indemnités pour ça ça prend du temps
vous trouvez ça normal que ça prenne
autant de temps pourtant pourtant c'est
des familles qui auraient été
intoxiquées à moins que non le
chlordécone était interdite partout dans
le monde il a été accepté aux antilles
mais c'était un bon produit d'accord
c'est un bon produit mais et la loi
jusqu'à présent n'est pas capable de
résoudre le problème puisque vous qui
est il qu'ils passent du dollar brembo
quoi justement qu'elle évoquerait même
montcelleux l'indemnisation ou celle de
l'existence c'est l'interrogation c'est
l'existence de la dérogation et c'est
l'indemnisation pourquoi vous avez vous
vous mettez pas vous qui avez travaillé
aux antilles vous qui connaissez les
problématiques pourquoi vous mettez pas
votre talent de juristes sur ces
questions d'indemnisation de famille qui
clame 9 avec leur famille ont été
intoxiqués par le chlordécone et les
voulais le dégager au mieux les demandes
ont été faites j'y mets et moi ça en est
où il faut pas pourquoi la rapidité ne
n'est pas aussi n'est pas passé dans les
a aimés pour vacciner il suffit de
claquer dont vous pensez dès que ces
gens si on était du coup savamment vous
pensez que ces gens qui ont été
constamment un constamment humilié
constamment mis de côté il ya eu
l'esclavagé pas d'indemnités d'accord il
ya eu les les affaires de mai 67 qu'on
appelle les événements de mai 67
premiers événements de mai 67 racisme
deuxième événement il se battait pour
des acquis sociaux il ya eu des morts
pas de coupable pas d'indemnités
pourquoi vous avez famille votre talent
de juristes sur ses causes madame mais
oui mais vous devez faire chouchouter
chinon mario sa maison que c'est une
demande incroyable de dire qu'on veut
pas se faire vacciner à qui on a
toujours menti oui madame son atom et
bien sûr les gens mais va mercredi aux
parties mais cela n'est comme ailleurs
il fait bon voyage je vais pas les sales
arabes a été rétablie par jean-claude
française avant par le droit quand il ya
eu les affaires de mai 67 je suis désolé
mais dites-moi quand il ya eu les
affaires de mai 67 il n'ya pas ya eu des
victimes il n'y a pas eu de coupables
jusqu'à présent mais cela dit jade et il
n'y a pas que la ksa arrive un nom mais
je dire mais quand vous allez lui disait
parler de spécificités parlait de
d'histoire par led oui on peut même
parler de schizophrénie nous sommes un
pays brasser nous sommes un pays mix
nous sommes un pays où la population de
ce pays et afro descendantes dont les
ancêtres ont été déportés et mise en
esclavage un pays où il ya des indiens
qui sont arrivés avec des rois avec les
vaccins 8 août un rapport madame où il
ya eu des annonces
qui sont arrivés avec des contrats et
qui n'ont jamais pu retourner chez eux
et qu'ils ont été aussi mise en
esclavage nous sommes un pays où il ya
une domination qui existe et des lots
vie qui font ce qu'il veut avec l'état
et qu'à part un flou juridique arrive à
imposer leur loi dont mettez vos talents
tous ces gens qui ont des talents de
juriste au service de ces populations
qui souffrent de mai de huy qui s'ouvre
depuis des années que d'issia je pense
que c'est pour ça que je disais je
parlais tout à l'heure convoqué
l'histoire me semble important pour
comprendre aussi les réactions des uns
et des autres mais ce n'est pas parce
que on est sur des réactions qui peuvent
sembler contraires à la protection de sa
propre personne et de ses 2 et de ses
proches et de la population qu'il faut
aller au delà de la justification mais
on comprend c'est pour ça que vous
vraiment voulu dire qu'il y avait deux
camps et que certains ont une méfiance
réel
il y avait deux n'avaient pas
déterminé de refermer et effectivement
nous qui sommes antienne nous comprenons
les réactions des uns et des autres cela
ça ne veut pas dire que nous les
acceptons forcément moi je moi je suis
vacciné je voulais trouver un je suis
vacciné et je comprends l'importance de
se vacciner même si nous nous nous
naviguons à vue
on ne sait pas ce que sera ce que nous
serons dans un an si on nous demandera
pas de faire un dixième 1/10 rappel nous
ne savons pas c'est la grande inconnue
et mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui vous
disiez quelque chose tout à l'heure en
préambule vous disiez ce n'est pas parce
que si on règle la problématique du pass
va veut
sanitaires aux antilles et autres ça ne
réglera rien il y aura encore parce
qu'en réalité le fond c'est un faux
c'est un rapport entre la france l'état
français je parle pas des français je
parle de l'état français envers ces
territoires l'a regardée par ailleurs je
prends un exemple sur la nouvelle
calédonie lorsque vous entendez
aujourd'hui les uns et les autres parler
de la nouvelle calédonie vous avez le
sentiment qu'il n'ya plus de peuples
autochtones qu'il n'ya pas les
descendants de ceux que l'on a dont on a
spolié la terre la terre ancestrale et
vous entendez des responsables
politiques vous parler de la nouvelle
calédonie comme moi j'appelle la kanaky
comme de l'algérie française avant 62 en
vous disant la nouvelle calédonie doit
rester française je pense que le seul
mot le dernier mot revient à celles et
ceux dont c'est la terre pour revenir
aux antilles et donc c'est pour cela on
a je trouve je ne suis pas certain que
dans la pharmacie de la république il y
est les bonnes réponses pour soigner
tous ces maux de notre société
lesquels on peut dire sous la halle
calédonie c'est quand même assez
incroyable qu'un pays aussi riche et une
population endogène celle à qui
appartient la nouvelle calédonie soit
aussi pauvre voilà non non on est tous
les aventures je serais beaucoup plus
nuancée que madame je me permettrai de
trouver un petit peu
très violente de qualifié de ridicule
quelque chose qui est très complexe la
deuxième chose concernant votre côté
constitutionnaliste que je respecte j'ai
un profond respect pour la loi quoique
on peut dire que d'autres ont dit que le
fai précède le droit le droit ce n'est
pas quelque chose de figé c'est quelque
chose qui qui se construit au fil du
temps et même la constitution qui est
sacrée mais bien sûr c'est une chance à
la paix elle permet tous les changements
des deux types aussi long donc vous avez
des référendums et justement donc on
peut effectivement c'est pas les
référendum commenté
me manquer mais on peut on peut on peut
faire preuve d'empathie centre est et de
ridicule nantis situation comparé la
situation qui peut la faire dit tu vois
que ça
qui vous paraît que sont défensives axe
que ce soit aux antilles ou ailleurs
c'est la même chose on d'aidé une
revendication qui n'est pas rationnelle
et qui frôle le riddim mais je suis
désolé je mangeais actionnaire je ne
suis pas sûr je doive laisser à
l'arrivée du sec trop facile mais c'est
trop facile de dire cela que
quelque chose qui n'est pas rationnelle
et ridicule vous basez sur quoi pour dit
pour dire cela moi je pense que
justement ce qui est intéressant dans la
pensée dans la pensée antillaise
dans la pensée reese hommes c'est la
notion de complexité et nous entrons
dans une notion de complexité on peut
dire que sur le plan national il y a eu
véritablement une solidarité nationale
qui a joué on en prend acte et nous en
sommes fiers
mais je pense que effectivement l'état
l'état français à jouer la concertation
et elle ouvre un champ de concertation
avec les élus locaux et les élus locaux
font un travail exceptionnel
important en ce moment avec les
syndicats avec la population pour ici de
trouver des chemins de traverse qui sont
des chemins qui nous permettront de
sortir de l'ornière non seulement sur le
plan local mais sur le plan national et
ça je je je tire mon chapeau à la fois
aux politiques nationaux aux politiques
locaux aux élus locaux parce que vous
avez je me permets de le dire et je ne
veux pas sortir de mes gonds une espèce
vous avez vous avez une espèce de mépris
indicible quand vous dites effectivement
on a l'impression de se retrouver dans
un truc féodal mais qui a inventé la
furent invités on se dépanne elle est là
la féodalité et et le système
dit universel oui une
histoire particulière est l histoire de
la déportation de la colonisation du
génocide c'est pareil il ya un système
mis en place
il y à des niveaux non mais il ya des
maintien de deux compagnies de
clientélisme oui et là voilà ça
s'appelle le clientélisme c'est à savez
je suis très souvent en afrique et dans
bon nombre de capitales ou de quartiers
de certaines capitales et dans les
villes secondaires bien plus encore vous
avez effectivement des coupures
d'électricité des coupures d'eau vous
n'avez pas d'eau de 14 heures à 18
heures il n'y a que sur le continent où
je vais souvent que je vois ça pas
seulement je retrouve sa également en
guadeloupe je ne retrouve ça dans aucun
territoire de france hexagonale je
retrouve ça en guadeloupe et je me dis
mais comment est-ce possible mais le
réseau d'eau bon et normal et de la
blague centralisée de veau et me oui oui
totalement non mais non ce n'est pas la
faute de l'état s'il ya des fuites
partout
c'est les élus luiza ilie l'iab pour moi
les voilà pour moi vous savez on va
arrêter de dire l'étendue tamari paris
paraître la france est un pays
décentralisé dont romeyer sont
particulièrement en plus d'autonomie que
les autres quand il ya un an blême en
bretagne ça ne concerne pas l'état quand
il ya un problème
dans les bouches-du-rhône ça ne concerne
à d'abord essayé dans my lenovo lettre
du maire et le préfet je dois dire que
c'est la faute
il fait quoi il n'est pas au courant en
fait de ce qui se passe mais
l'intelligence madame je sais que
l'adresse ne m est pas responsable
artistes
corruption non mais parce que enfin
reste mon élection donc où jeanne la
pucelle il faut ritter diabolique qui se
sont succédé en guadeloupe n'était pas
au courant de ce qui se passait deux
fois mais dilemme de corruption d'eau de
problèmes de problème de l'eau tu fais
une gestion des nuls donc non mais ça
j'ai bien compris voilà on sait très
bien que c'est gestion des élus locaux
et que ce sont des élus qui ont été
corrompus d'accord mais à aucun moment à
aucun moment le préfet
n'avait l'air bourru et l'information
commenté l'information à aucun moment le
droit a qu à aucun moment l'état ne
pouvait agir c'est à dire on est
français d'accord sont des français ça
on n'est pas français et on est français
a même titre que la bretagne un même
type que les bouches du rhône est ce qu
un moment quand il ya ce problème de
corruption des mères le préfet est-ce
que ça des pelles même problème qui a
rien de recettes jerry france par
exemple c'est à dire qu'il est avec vous
il en avait le pouvoir
est au fond l'état et mais l'état tels
armements toulouse on verra peut-être le
jour menacée il est sous pression en
permanence puisqu'on lui dit que c'est
de sa faute si l'état se met à lancer
des poursuites contre un élu je peux
vous dire que ici prend à deux fois
parce que il va y avoir une réaction
locale il va y avoir une manipulation
locale contre l'état je les magistrats
tremblent les préfets comme sont menacés
souvent vous savez un préfet et la femme
d'un ancien préfet de corse me disait
qu'elle recevait à noël des petits
cercueils au nom de toute la famille et
des ans aborde sans fil mais rien à
faire
nous partons vers le passé on a déplacé
le temps je vous interromps on remontera
l'allée tard juste à moi je vous avais
avant j'allais faire à l'état ça je peux
vous le dire et je suis témoin
[Musique]
la dette est elle la niche où l'ennemi
de la croissance aujourd'hui on continue
à s'endetter et c'est même devenu un
modèle économique et ça depuis une
quinzaine d'années où vous avez le la
croissance qui n'est que la croissance
de la dette en fait est ce que pour
générer plus de profit plus de richesse
créée est ce que c'est bon d'avoir
injecté encore plus en fait d'argent qui
ne m'appartient pas qui va falloir du
remboursement donner la réponse est
évidente pour tout ce qu'on a mis le si
peu de résultats mais c'est pathétique
là ils n'utilisent de la dette pour
manger tous les jours si vous voulez pas
pour investir et donc pour payer les
dépenses publiques de tous les jours de
fonctionnement et à partir de ce moment
là vous savez que vous n'allez pas
générer plus tard de l'argent avec cette
dette
[Musique]
la nouvelle calédonie où l'ultime
référendum sur l'indépendance est
maintenue au 12 décembre quel poids
représente aujourd'hui à 1000 mots
khadem les indépendantistes dans le
paysage politique en nouvelle calédonie
qu il ya une progression du oui le
peuple originel concernés par la
dépendance il l'indépendance une
d'atlantis au camp il représente la
france pour la société calédonienne il
ya pas eu de et noir auger de la france
et ses alliés quand même qu'il ait pas
ça c'est un lien de consumérisme
d'assistanat ou ce que dit j'ai un
économiste une économie assistée sous
perfusion si on fait des statistiques
cruel pour vous retrouver plus de kanaks
dans les prisons pour les hôpitaux
psychiatriques on marche une société que
dans la réussite au niveau social
[Musique]
on reprend un autre débat sur la crise
sociale aux antilles avec luc laventure
avec keziah libre et anne marie le
pourhiet tu es claudy siar je vois la
parole adnane le poète mais juste pour
résumer où on en était grosso modo
l'état est au courant mais il ne fait
rien aux rien faire il ne fait rien
parce que pour si l'état agisse et pour
sanctionner contrôler donc pour exercer
une autorité or l'autorité de l'état est
totalement contestée en permanence donc
c'est un système c'est une quadrature du
cercle en fait et j'ai lu un rapport
d'un préfet sur le contrôle de légalité
des collectivités locales pour l'année
ça devait être 94 ou 95 il faisait une
demi-page c'était un bout de papier
rapports sur le contrôle de légalité sur
un an et en martinique alors que vous
voyez à l'oeil nu tous les inégalités
qui sont commises et et qui tenait en
une demi page et qu'est ce qu'il dit en
gros j'ai fermé les yeux sur la fin j'ai
fermé les yeux ce n'est pas agi je n'ai
pas poursuivi je n'ai pas saisi les
chambres régionales des comptes le
tribunal administratif etc
devant le saucissonnage des marchés
publics parce que l'ordre public le
requérait c'est à dire si jamais je fais
ça je fait flamber
la société il va y avoir d'aidé d'état
de ce conte d'habilitation de ré de
répondre d' insulte des élus locaux qui
vont dire mais comment mais comment mais
pas du tout jeune je n'ai rien fait et
caetera et donc il ya risque d'atteinte
à l'ordre public et le risque d'atteinte
à l'ordre public et la menace l'épée de
damoclès qui pèse en permanence donc
vous voyez c'est un cercle vicieux
après c'est à dire quelque chose parce
que là mais je suis mais vraiment je
suis horrifié je n'ai pas scandalisé
parce que je ne crois pas ce que vous
dites je suis vraiment horrifié par ce
que vous dites vous dites quoi vous dit
le préfet ne sert à rien c'est quand
même grave je peux vous dire je vais
donner des noms l'actuel directeur de
cabinet de l'actuel ministre de
l'outre-mer buste il a pris une sanction
concernant après le fait concernant un
maire il l'a fait de façon
de façon légale
certains ont dit de façon brutale il a
joué son rôle de préfet quand vous avez
des gens comme carenco préfet carenco on
a que je peux vous donner des listes de
préfets qui ont qui ont assumé leur rôle
de représentant de l'état et qui n'ont
pas peur
de quelques manifestations de quelques
semaines ce soit la pardonnez moi madame
donc je pense que quand vous dites cela
vous jeter l'opprobe sur un corps que
j'estime être corps d'élite et qui
représente l'état la deuxième chose je
pense que effectivement ça dépend il y a
eu des préfets en corse qui ont qui ont
assumé leur rôle et qu'ils l'ont payé de
leur vie bon donc je pense que vous ne
pouvez pas dire cela la troisième chose
que j'ai envie de dire la démocratie
c'est un rapport de force permanent est
ce un rapport de 2
jusqu'à ce qu'on trouve effectivement
les chemins de traverse qui permettent
aux populations d'évoluer vous visiez
parler d'eux des nitrates
en bretagne combien de temps ça a pris
pour que ça soit réglé mais c'est la
règle et s'adonne à risque ce que je
connais loin il montrait que je veux
dire entre les lobbys de l'agriculture
qu'on retrouve partout et les problèmes
de santé qui s'étire à c'est un rapport
effectivement de j'avance je n'avance
pas je retire et c'est partout pareil
donc dont donc je ne vois pas vous poser
un problème 2 de droit constitutionnel
mais qui évolue de façon permanente et
je ne vois pas en quoi
l'état est décrédibilisé dans ces
territoires
justement faut faire avancer des justes
je voulais j'ai récusée antarès en cause
des problèmes on perd même sociaux
lancés de ça justement là
que j'ai entendu le procès de l'état il
ya une spéciale tandis que le disait que
justement il ya il ya l'état en
guadeloupe et qu'à un moment donné
l'état était au courant du problème de
l'eau et que l'état devait faire son
travail de sanctions je vous aurais dit
ce qu'elles savaient pas ce qu'on
n'abordait question j'aimerais qu'on en
arrive justement a eu des singularités
de la descente i c'est quand même la vie
chère la pauvreté le chômage une
jeunesse
inoccupés j'ai envie de dire parce que
simplement il n'y a aucune perspective
et une jeunesse et ça c'est quand même
très particulier alors là aussi
d'ailleurs on en accuse l'état en france
est-ce qu'on a raison est ce que c'est
un nouveau problème est qu'il n'ya pas
assez d'entreprises aux antilles pas
assez d'emplois privés justement alors
je vais parler de la jeunesse mais je
vais vous dire à quel moment où si on
peut accuser l'état
2009 crise en outre-mer 20 janvier en
guadeloupe ça ne février en martinique
44 jours de grève avec une réponse de
l'état qui dit en tout cas qui nous
semblent nous comprendre la situation
est à généraux de l'outre-mer
luc et moi et toi kesa je pense nous
avons participé à des à des commissions
réfléchi le président sarkozy à l'époque
sur la question de la culture et de la
visibilité
décide que france ô qui était sur une
tnt régionale deviendrait une chaîne
nationale afin que les originaires
d'outre-mer puisse s'exprimer que tous
les français puissent comprendre
qu'elles sont jolies ritournelles et par
dont les jambes étaient fusent j'avais
justement se rendre tous les honneurs
chez lui puisque luc laventure était
l'un des artisans de cela de cette
chaîne là et durand et durant plusieurs
années et cette chaîne a été supprimée
dire que pour la première fois dans
l'histoire est et je suis les meubles
par la présidence de france télévisions
par l'état l'état l'état non létales à
supprime le cette chaîne à qui était une
gêne importante pour la cohésion
nationale pour comprendre et la crise
aujourd'hui or si cette chaîne avait
encore exister peut-être que là on
aurait pu discuter autrement et en tant
d'autres voies on a vu il ya un an deux
ans et c'est assez régulier
les jeunes en martinique et en
guadeloupe déboulonne des statues de
grands personnages français ils ont
déboulonné shell cher alors on pourrait
là encore argumenté sur celle cher moi
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent que
celle cher n'a pas été boulonné mais ce
déboulonnage là en réalité ce n'est pas
la statue qui est importante et même le
symbole qu'il était chaque catcheur qui
était lui-même
lisez donc mais mais mais exactement en
réalité c'est en réalité c'est une
attaque c'est une attaque très clair
envers les dans dix ans aujourd'hui la
situation qu'elle a d'autres situations
sociales le rapport que nous avons à la
france ce mépris persistant
entretenu et par par l'état français je
dis bien par l'état français n'est plus
acceptable vous avez une jeunesse qui
est extrêmement consciente de sa réalité
extrêmement conscient de comment se
fait-il qu'il n'y ait pas à
développement endogène possible avec les
autres régions de la caraïbe comment se
fait-il que sur des terres vous l'avez
dit où le chômage est endémique très
fort où la pauvreté est la réelle
comment se fait-il que des produits de
première nécessité soient plus chers
qu'ailleurs comme si nous habitions
siaka permis plus cher qu'à paris en
tout cas plus cher qu'en région
parisienne effectivement comme si nous
étions au cap ferret ou ou à saint
tropez est donc là vous avez une colère
grandissante et avec une jeunesse encore
une fois qui est extrêmement qui
comprend connaît son histoire et qui est
très éduquée mais comment pouvez vous
dire comment ça se fait que les prix
soient plus cher là-bas mais vous savez
bien pourquoi alors dit depuis le temps
oui que les économistes la cnes de la
fac de droit la martinique je vous ai
mon message est celui dont il attendait
les années
continues et éthéré alors justement vous
voyez par exemple mais selon rawad mais
leur propre mais il sert à quelque chose
sont d'accord dans la continuité tant
rien s'il a le transport non mais si
l'état français n'est pas capable
d'assumer cette continuité territoriale
savez l'espagne mais c'est quoi
l'intérêt des toilettes dit clairement
ce que nous avons dit oui maintenant
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire assurer la
continuité territoriale que l'espagne
est capable de faire avec ces
territoires certainement moins savez
lorsque j'étais délégué interministériel
travail sur la téléphonie mobile et nous
avions réuni lors d'une la dernière
grande manoeuvre en réunion nous avons
réuni tous les directeurs généraux des
compagnies de téléphonie momie et nous
étions le 20 mars alors en plus le 19
mars en vie voilà accès c'est un moment
un peu historique et j'avais expliquer
aux uns et aux autres que vous ne pouvez
plus apporté l'argument de la distance
pour expliquer le coût de la
communication de
sur la téléphonie mobile et
qu'aujourd'hui il était par le numérique
par par la technologie et peut-être même
par la france il était possible de
régler les problèmes que les français
d'outre-mer et la même tarification il
n'y avait pas à ce moment là en 2012 il
n'y avait pas encore de deux forfaits
illimités et c'est comme cela c'est
grâce à l'amont actions et des idéaux
des associations battu également fuir
mais voilà on est arrivé à ça je donne
un autre principe que l'état accorde à
certains et refuse aux gens doutent
rohmer lorsque vous attestez d'une
adresse en corse votre billet que ce
soit pour le transport de votre voiture
sur le bateau ou d'avion vous le payez
moins cher pourquoi ce principe que la
république accorde à certains n'est pas
accordée à d'autres originaires
d'outre-mer voyez c'est là où les
disparités sont et c'est là vous avez
des originaires d'outre-mer qui vous
disent c'est pas impossible
et on a tâché de gazole à luc laventure
madame madame magritte où l'immense
respect que j'ai pour vous avez commencé
votre exposé tout à l'heure aux docks
c'est irrécupérable
ils réformable pardonnez moi je je je
rejoins ce que dit
mon petit frère si je me mettais mon
petit frère qui dit la chose suivante le
combat est un combat permanent qui ont
ramené et je crois cela on a parlé de
deux choses il a parlé par exemple des
jeunes au niveau de l'histoire c'est c
nous allons travailler nous sommes en
train de travailler ensemble d'ailleurs
avec outremer 360 et d'autres
associations sur le fait d'eux non pas
de réécrire l'histoire ni d'être dans un
espèce de rock américain et cetera mais
de faire en sorte que nous ayons parce
que nous avons également nos héros qu'on
ne met pas qu'on ne met pas en valeur du
tout et sur lequel on va travailler
parce que la république elle est pour
moi l est et je suis content que vous
ayez cette décoration et nous la portons
avec avec beaucoup de bonheur la
république ce n'est pas quelque chose de
ce mot parisien c'est quelque chose qui
doit être alimenté comme
avec le sang de chacun d'entre nous de
chacune de nos régions j'appartiens à
une famille à la martinique et qu'ils à
le disait grâce si si si la france si de
gaulle à exister ces bacs grâce à des
gens comme félix et bruit
qui son petit fils d'esclave
en guyane qui ont fait que effectivement
grâce à lui de gaulle a pu avoir un
territoire physique qui lui a permis
d'avoir à la fois des sommes un
territoire physique est également de
l'argent pour acheter justement le
matériel de guerre et qui lui a permis
effectivement de rentrer dans le concert
des nations qui s'est levé contre
l'allemagne ça c'était porteur et on
n'en parle pas et il faut que nous
puissions nous écrire cette histoire et
montrer que nous avons payé l'impôt du
sens pour être français n'ont pas
français de souche comme on aime le dire
mais que nous avons payé notre écho à
cette république qui est la nôtre et
c'est pourquoi je ne suis pas d'accord
avec vous sur le côté de un réforme à
bhl tout est réformable la constitution
doit être
améliorée en permanence et nous allons
buriné l'ensemble
de la statue de la république pour que
nous ne puissions y imprimer notre
marque récit national
non et bien justement alors je vous
prends je voudrais de travailler chez
moi mais je me dis aux jeunes qu'ils ont
subies par les belles je ne suis pas sur
ce genre de liste modem pas sûr que ça
jamais oublier alors j'ai un rapport à
la droite prépare très particulier c'est
parce que mémé maison que justement on
fait ce qu'on appelle la dissidence par
rapport à la loi pour pouvoir aller à la
dominique au péril de leur vie j'en ai
perdu 1 pour pouvoir rejoindre les
forces françaises libres et tu le disais
tout à l'heure et c'est grâce à ce
rapport à la loi un peu particulier que
nous avons que nous avons scruté
justement cette vème république je vais
encore aller plus loin concernant les
jeunes de façon très concrète très
concrètes je vais travailler il y a
quelques années mais je vais me
reprendre ce dossier avec se donne
d'associations j'étais à sarcelles
démange dernier et avec un snob
d'associations nous allons monter c'est
un scoop que je donne ici si je puis
dire nous allons monter une espèce de
2,2 touquet format tic où nous allons
demander aux jeunes qui veulent faire
quelque chose on doit monter une espèce
de club et à partir de là nous allons
monter une plate forme numérique qui
permettra de servir de lien entre les
petites entreprises qui n'ont pas le
temps justement de suivre ces jeunes de
façon à donner beaucoup d'importance à
cette irrigation concernant l'emploi et
tu le disais tout à l'heure c'est vrai
quand on s'aperçoit que les moins de 25
ans il y à 60 % de chômage aux antilles
alors que le taux de chômage pour les
moins de 25 ans et 2 15 à 20% sur le
plan d'hexagone donc rien des ti
réformable au contraire et je demande et
il en parle ici et je souhaite que cette
solidarité s'exprime de façon totale
nous allons continuer continuer
continuer à avancer avancer avancer pour
que nous soyons que nous puissions
irrigué de nos deux noms comme
angélique aventure mais il ya le
problème on le reconnaît il ya un
déficit d'emplois privés aux antilles
qui est considérable voilà au tout le
monde pour ne pouvant pas être
fonctionnaire il faut bien qu'ils aient
des emplois là et dont il est donc il
faut un développement endogène tu me
parles devant alors il ya une jeunesse
vous savez la jeunesse n'est pas
seulement celle qui est qu'ils sont sur
les ronds points mais il faut pas
négliger celles qui sont sur les brand
points parce qu'ils revendiquent ils ont
aussi des revendications et ce qu'ils
ont des revendications sur les problèmes
d'éducation parce que vous savez
monsieur ce que demande la
guadeloupe et la martinique
c'est d'être d'avoir les le même
fonctionnement que
les jeunes
français de l'hexagone jeu ils veulent à
temps ils veulent du travail d'accord
ils veulent une bonne éducation
seulement ils veulent que toutes ces
grosses sociétés qui se monte en
guadeloupe et société de propriétaires
qui vivent en hexagone qui sont les
puissances de l'hexagone qui se montrent
en quoi le père m'a dit embauches ces
jeunes parce que vous savez depuis le
bus mis d'hommes où la guadeloupe et la
martinique a été des peuples et parce
que et la réunion aussi pour que les
ultra marins viennent travailler ici aux
ptt chez simca chez renault
et pour dans les métiers de services
médicaux médical les hôpitaux
pourquoi c'est parce qu'ils avaient
beaucoup de chômage donc au lieu de
développer le pays ils ont préféré
enlever les guadeloupéens et les
martiniquais pour venir travailler ici
d'accord et ils ont des peuples et la
guadeloupe ils n'ont pas voulu faire
progresser ce pays développés ce pays
économiquement à l'époque de mes parents
en guadeloupe on faisait des yaourts
voilà on faisait du contreplaqué il y
avait du sucre mais il faut qu'on a
trouvé la betterave ea sola plus besoin
du sucre de là bas une fois qu'on a
toutes utilisées et que le chômage
montait il a pris ils ont préféré vider
le pays que construire le pays pour que
les jeunes puissent rester nous ils ont
mis en place le bus mis d'hommes pour
que les jeunes viennent ici et ne puisse
pas repartir et aujourd'hui on a encore
ce problème de chômage avec des
contenaires d'aliments qui arrive pour
que les gens s e
se nourrir avec des produits avec trop
de sucre et devenir obèses voilà donc
c'est devenu ils touchent le rsa il
touche le chômage et puis ensuite il
achète ce sont devenus des consommateurs
sur pied mais eux c'est parce qu'ils
veulent monsieur ils veulent partir
faire des études et revenir chez eux
travailler c'est ça la réalité on les
fait passer pour des fainéants c'est
faux vous savez depuis l'abolition de
l'esclavagé
les antillais sont devenus fainéants dès
qu'ils ont commencé à demander les
droits sociaux de qui se donnent ils ont
commencé à demander l'égalité des
salaires voilà le problème donc bien sûr
les élus sont corrompus bien sûr qu'il
ya des lobbys toujours les mêmes mais la
jeunesse c'est terrible ce qui lui
arrive et ce n'est pas une jeunesse
méchante c'est une jeunesse qui n'en
peuvent plus c'est une jeunesse qui
regardent la télé qui voit les autres
s'en sortir c'est une jeunesse qui veut
retourner vivre dans son pays et pour ça
il ya le député olivier servent à
président de la délégation outre-mer qui
connaît un jeune qui s'appelle yens 30
ans et qui a monté une association qui
s'appelle aller vini et à les virer en
martinique avec la soul à l'aide de la
de la sénatrice
cancun je te regarde pour que les jeunes
qui sont ici après leurs études puissent
revenir ce qu'il faudrait mettre comme
solidarité c'est de dire à ces sociétés
qui monte des grosses structures en
guadeloupe d'embaucher les jeunes
guadeloupéens martiniquais qui veulent
rentrer vivre ici et puisqu'en france il
ya un racisme contre les noirs et que
les majorités des jeunes d'accord qui
ont des problèmes de chômage sont noirs
ils veulent bien repêché eux comme ça
ici ils auront moins de noirs et ils
seront contents de travailler chez ce
monsieur les jeunes veulent travailler
chez eux anne marie le pourhiet
c'était si vous voulez c'est le type de
discours qu'on entend tout le temps et
il ya vingt ans quand on allait il
fallait pas célébrer les fêtes et il
fallait commémorer du bout des lèvres la
loi de départementalisation de 1946
quand j'étais là-bas il n'y avait que
des colloques des colloques et on colle
au cul comme ça c'est à dire on disait
il ya qu'à faut que et puis tout le
monde se plaint et tout le monde se
plaint et puis ça recommence rien n'est
niveau lui c'est ce que j'entends
aujourd'hui c'est ce que j'entends
depuis 30 ans c'est tout le temps tout
le temps tout le temps et rien ne change
parce que finalement si rien ne change
mais je ne pense pas je pense que les
choses évoluent nos chats très bien que
rien ne changera le guépard non 6 des
outre-mer dont la place des droits on
n'attend pas failli à la
nationalité une référence à visconti
non parce que tu te fais dit deux choses
importantes sur l'iss effectivement le
taux de sucre dans les aliments vendus
en outre-mer serait juste rappeler que
le l'ancien président de région devenue
ministre les autres maires victorin
lurel en 2013 justement a fait voter une
loi pour que cela cesse lorsque vous
dites que finalement le les discours
sont souvent les mêmes juste rappeler
qu'en 2017 le crefor nous avons fait
voter une loi sur l'égalité réelle et
6,6 des femmes et des hommes sont encore
sur les barricades au sens propre et au
sens figuré c'est bien parce qu'il y a
un problème persistant et que l'on a du
mal à faire entendre raison à l'état
lorsque le ministre d outre-mer
après discussion avec certains élus dit
je suis prêt à ouvrir le débat autour de
l'autonomie alors pour un guadeloupéen
comme moi qui ait des velléités
indépendantistes mais dans vingt ou
trente ou quarante ans si les
populations le souhaitent une hirondelle
ne fait pas le printemps
ça peut être flatteur même pour moi ça
ne l'est pas un ministre d outre mer et
en 2009 nous avions déjà entendu ça on
ne peut pas à chaque fois qu'il ya des
revendications légitimes ou une colère
légitime nous dit où combien coûte
l'outre-mer à la france donc cela veut
dire que nous ne sommes pas totalement
français si vous nous si vous n'êtes pas
contents nous sommes prêts à discuter
sur la question de l'autonomie alors je
pense qu'une majorité d'anti encore une
fois ce que moi je pense ne ne vaut rien
au regard de la majorité de ce que la
majorité souhaite et la majorité ne
parle pas d'indépendance elle part juste
d'une égalité réelle et c'est vrai que
c'est le gouvernement parler d'eux amy
vous parler par exemple d'égalité réelle
mais vous savez comment les prix sont
tirés également par le haut et tout est
tiré par le haut et y compris les
salaires du privé parce que évidemment
dans les salaires du privé et que vous
avez des fonctionnaires ou des agents
publics qui touchent des salaires bien
plus important et qu'en plus ça c'est
quand il des emplois et caetera et bien
le salarié du privé il peut même pas
empruntés dans les mêmes conditions que
le fonctionnaire bon donc évidemment
depuis des années des années des années
ce système de surrémunération de la
fonction publique dren toutes les forces
vives de la martinie moi j'ai eu des
étudiants qui aurait pu faire des
juristes d'entreprise formida il n'avait
qu'une idée c'est d'aller s'asseoir
derrière un guichet il fallait de
fonctionner bon il faut être fonctionner
même si je sais que je peux y est bien
évidemment c'est colossal surnombre mois
c'est énorme c'est énorme et puis
surtout ça vous donne un accès au crédit
et autres vous n'avez pas quand vous
d'abord ce système là est
évidemment un acte fou rire et dirait
vous n'avez pas ces livres et masoe
problème en entreprise vous l'avez pas
si vous voulez acheter une voiture vous
avez l'accès au crédit si vous voulez
faire de une entreprise vous n'avez pas
accès aux crédits si vous voulez acheter
une maison vous n'avez pas accès aux tno
s'est dit monsieur acheter une voix qui
vise à veiller aux
prévisions en une influence sur les prix
oui c était évident aussi vous savez pas
et j'ai des collègues économistes à la
faculté de droit de martinique qui ont
passé leur temps à tourner le système
dans tous les sens on ne trouve pas la
solution puisque c'est à elle c'est un
cercle vicieux comme ça donc qui est
prêt à mettre la question la
surrémunération sur la table se passe
quelque chose d vous en parlait il fait
mine les syndicats à feu et à sang qui
me fait très peur qui me fait très peur
en ce moment aux antilles
tout le monde dénoncé depuis de
nombreuses années le fait qu'il soit
facile pour des personnes venus de
l'hexagone que l'on appelle communément
aux antilles les métropolites assez pour
ne pas dire blanc
et qui dans le privé et dans la fonction
publique aussi à vous regarder parfois
d'un côté d'un côté vous avez tous les
chefs de service ils sont français
blancs et de l'autre français noirs
alors ceux qui revendiquent les sections
les gens des associations et donc et
donc
se développe aux antilles une sorte de
colère face à cette réalité là et vous
avez des antilles et noir qui maintenant
disent moi je si un blanc et un noir
postule je vais embaucher le noir et ça
ça peut être on parlait justement de
nous voulons tous faire nation lire
aujourd'hui les uns et les autres de
voulons faire nation mais ces inégalités
la et ses réflexes là vous parlez des
ces jeunes qui sont au rond point il ya
les jeunes qui sont au rond-point qui
manifestent leur colère légitime et vous
avez ceux effectivement comme j'en vois
moi en afrique dans certaines villes des
coupeurs de route qui rackettent et cela
évidemment les dénonce évidemment on ne
peut pas se sentir solidaire de cette et
ceux qui rackettent des antillais qui
eux mêmes ou aller travailler ou aller
faire leurs courses ou aller acheter des
médicaments pour une personne âgée à la
maison ça me paraît évident il faut je
crois qu'il faut séparer il ya deux
catégories et ceux qui revendiquent dont
il faut entendre les revendications
et lorsque l'état vous dis on va
peut-être débattre autour de la de
l'autonomie je trouve ça presque
insultant dernier pour luc l'aventuré
n'aurait qu'une attention à une chose
c'est que j'ai remarqué souvent que cet
appel à l'état permanent
la france n'est pas un état
collectiviste ce n'est pas l'état qui
crée des emplois dans un ami commerçant
personnel a dit plus
soit mais non
c'est vous qu'on soit nombreux nationaux
d'abord c'est moi alors d'accord non non
non madame a raison non non je suis
désolé madame harel non madame a raison
pensez vous qu'il soit normal que des
français et à ministère pour les gérer
qu'une catégorie de français ya
ministère gérer mais alors je peux je
peux vous alors là je peux vous dire est
constitutionnellement militante oui de
la suppression du ministère de votre
mère qui bombardent depuis bien
longtemps voilà mais je dois vous dire
que quand je prononce à aux antilles on
me dit elle est folle non non non non
les salaires on laisse le dernier mot
elle permet d'avoir un interlocuteur
privilégié pour les ultramarines usagers
c'est le mot coeur d'avoir quelqu'un qui
s'occupe de vous comme le ministère hong
lei ce dernier mois luc laventure aussi
beaucoup de ces diamants jeudi l'achat
je vais dans la foulée de ce que
viennent de dire que les
basques viennent de dire qu'ils allaient
dire moi je dois moi je suis optimiste
moi je crois à cette nouvelle génération
qui arrive dans le digital et ses
terrains et tu as un réseau qui veut
créer de l'emploi local est de plus en
plus on croit je crois à soi et à ses
jeunes ensemble nous allons leur donner
un coup de main pour qu'il représente
justement les outre mer de façon
flamboyante
joliment terre je vous remercie tous les
cadres d'avoir participé à ce débat
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]